all right um
okay it's a pleasure to have uh ron and
eldon today
um he he'll be telling us about
[Music]
concentration bounds using stochastic
calculus for boolean functions
ronan received his
phd from the tel aviv university and
he's been at microsoft research and now
he's
currently at the weizmann institute
of
really fantastic work on the telegram
conjecture
on convex geometry on kls
conjecture and on
on bandits in convex geometry and
and a whole sequence of works on this
and today he'll tell us about his
latest work on using stochastic calculus
approaches for
boolean function analysis
thank you so much prasad for this
introduction and the invitation
i'm always super happy to be in berkeley
in this uh nice weather
there's an air conditioner here so it
actually doesn't matter so much where i
am
um all right so um
let me start so i guess uh
the intro part will be easier
in this series of talks because i guess
most participants have already seen
what a boolean function is so our
setting is just going to be we're
going to have some function f from minus
1 1 to the n
2 minus 1 1. this is a boolean function
and mu is going to be
the uniform measure on the
hypercube
maybe let's fix the notation c
n to be minus 1 1 to the n
okay and today
so so this talk is going to talk to
is going to uh revolve around
concentration inequalities what are
concentration inequalities those are
basically
in quantities that bound the global
oscillation of a function
by the local oscillation so we want to
say that if
function is not oscillating too much
locally then it's also not oscillating
too much globally
and how do we measure oscillation so
the global oscillation will usually be
measured via the variance of a function
so let's all agree that the expectation
of
f will just stand for
the integral of f d mu
and the variance of f
will just be uh
the expectation of f squared minus the
expectation of
f squared since f is a boolean function
this first term
is always one right
now so that's our way to measure global
oscillation
what's uh how do we measure the local
oscillation for this
the the notion we like
is the notion of discrete derivatives
we just want to see how big they are so
let's define the discrete derivative the
partial derivative of
f in direction i at the point x
to be just f of
x 1 up to x
i minus 1 and then i force the i
coordinate to be 1 x i plus 1
etc
minus the same thing where i now force
the i-coordinate to be minus 1.
and it's gonna be kind of convenient to
normalize this by dividing by two
doesn't matter so much
so this is the i discrete derivative
and the discrete gradient at x is just
going to be the vector of discrete
derivatives
good and we're going to say that a
function is not oscillating so much
locally
if it's you know partial derivatives
at the point are small
um a notion that we're also going to
like
is the i influence of f
which is just going to be the
expectation
of the eighth derivative of f
squared of course the derivative is
either
0 1 or -1 so the square here
doesn't matter so much but i'm leaving
it
because it's going to make sense for
some of the inequalities
which hold for functions which are
also not boolean real valued
and the total influence i of f is just
going to be
the sum of the
influences of coordinates okay so i
guess you've all seen those notations
several times in this
series of talks and
we're now ready to formulate the first
canonical concentration inequality which
is the poincare
inequality
so this is the most basic way to relate
local to global oscillation
it just tells us that the variance of f
is bounded by the
i think the con the right constant is
one
i'm pretty sure by the
total influence of f okay
the derivatives are small the function
does not vary
too much and
this it's not very hard to check that
this is
sharp so for which functions this is
sharp
in the boolean case it's only sharp for
a dictator
but if f is real valued it's not hard to
see that it's
sharp for linear functions
if and only if f is a linear function
actually
and when f takes the values minus 1 1
uh f is linear if and only if f
is a dictator
meaning f of f of x is just x i for some
i
okay um
good so so this is
uh the proof of this is very
easy if you know if you
know of the fourier decomposition we'll
see it a bit later
uh but now
the next thing i want to do is i want to
argue
that this inequality is very lacking in
the sense
that it doesn't at all
take advantage of the fact that f is
boolean
okay so it's it's actually true for any
real value dev
and there's there we're gonna see
several ways of taking advantage
of the fact that f is borean in
which will allow us to improve this
inequality in
several directions okay
so first of all let's notice
that it's far from sharp
so
so it's far from sharp for the case that
f is the majority function
okay we kind of would have expected you
know if it's sharp for a dictator
and our world would be isotropic
then you know majority is just some
rotation
of dictator but this inequality doesn't
work
well with the direction one one one one
it only works well with the direction
one zero zero zero so to see this
let's just quickly uh think what the
so the left hand side for a majority is
o of one
the right hand side for majority so
what's the probability that we are near
the boundary of f
that we're sensitive to one of the
coordinates
it's not hard to to see that this is
something like one over root n
but if we're sensitive to one coordinate
then we're
sensitive to something like o ven
coordinates
so we have probability 1 over root n to
be sensitive to
n coordinates which means the total
influence is something like
root n so for a majority we get like o
of one
less or equal to you know omega
of root n which is far from sharp
okay
so uh the question is is there a way to
fix
this in the sense of in meaning
is there a better inequality which is
sharp
for maybe all threshold functions
hopefully or weighted majorities
or something like that okay and the
answer is yes
there is an inequality by telegram
saying the following
thing we first need uh
maybe let's make a definition we define
this
local sensitivity of the function f
at x to be
the norm square of the gradient of
f at x
which is just equal to the number of
coordinates
i such that
f at x is not equal to
f at x with the i
coordinates toggled
and the poincare inequality can be
reformulated
as photos so we just have that
the variance of f is at most the
expectation
of h of f this is just another way to
write
the same inequality and what talagang
proved around
94 is that we can add a square root
inside the expectation here
so if you think about it for a minute
for majority
this is exactly okay up to a constant
actually i'm not sure what the constant
is
for majority this is exactly sharp up to
a constant
right because we have probability one
over root n
that the thin g inside the expectation
will be
root n so both sides are like
o of one okay this is
so this is the first strengthening
of the polanco inequality
um and now i want to discuss another
strengthening in some in
in a somewhat orthogonal direction
called the kkl inequality so
let's now recall what the can
cali and
lineal inequality is
so again let's go back to
poincare and think of a function
f that has variance
of one think of say a balanced function
we have probability one half to be equal
to plus one and one have to be equal to
minus one and
the question is what can i say about the
minimum
sorry what can i say about the maximal
influence of a coordinate
what does this ensure me somehow the
fact that
the variance of f is of one that there
is
at least one coordinate with
a big influence and how big is this
influence
by the way i see that there are
questions in the chat
from like i i i couldn't get a chance to
read them but if you guys want me to
answer this question
sure so let me look
just just let me know when there is a
question because i don't
know so you didn't miss it
i see so the telegram result
uh there is a version i mean
the version i wrote here doesn't make so
much sense if the function is not
boolean because we don't know what what
sensitivity would be
but yes it does extend to non-boolean
functions
and the way to extend it is really to
look at
like this definition we'll actually kind
of
ah yeah we'll kind of discuss this
in a bit
um i think there is also
someone in that wants to ask a question
let me allow him to talk
okay so morph martin
you want to ask a question
i'm not sure he's probably getting
coffee
so let's continue and maybe we would say
if there are questions in q a or in the
chat
okay so back to the discussion i started
so uh suppose i know that the variance
is of one
can this ensure that they have some
influence which is
not too small and really how how big
can i ensure that one of the influences
is
and you know what follows trivially from
poincare
is that there is at least one influence
which is
one over n right the sum of influences
is one
so one of the influences is one over n
and you know this gives rise to the
natural question
is there a construction of a function
such that
all of the influences are at most one
over n
even though the variance is like omega
of one
okay or is it the case that
you know maybe the structure the fact
that the function is boolean
the discrete structure maybe enforces
something better okay
and the inequality tells us
yeah you actually do get something
better
you get something better by a
logarithmic factor
so the kk kkl inequality
looks like this so it looks kind of like
that telegram inequality
but we also gain another term
we get to divide here by the
log of
e over the max influence
of the function
and it's not very hard to see that this
implies for example that
if var the variance of f
is omega of one then
okay so it implies this
implication that
there is a coordinate such that
its influence is at least
not one over n but log n over n
okay and this improvement by logins may
at first it may not look like a big deal
it's only a logarithmic improvement but
actually it has very far-reaching
consequences
which i'm not gonna discuss just
because i don't have so much time i
guess
uh good so what we saw so far
just to put this on a diagram we saw
that there is this poincare inequality
which is obviously it's implied by the
kkl inequality it's not very hard
to see that this is a strengthening
and
well then we had another inequality
which it's also
not hard to see that this implication is
also true but well
it's it's actually true
[Music]
under the extra assumption that the
variance is omega of one
so i'll discuss this a bit later but
maybe for now it's for now it's kind of
okay to assume that all the functions
we're looking at
have variants on the goat one
why isn't it true always like the
influence is like the expectation of h
of
a yeah this is bigger than one
always yeah you're right okay so for
boolean functions
i guess yeah yeah yeah for boolean
functions it's
yeah for boolean functions it's always
yeah you're right
so forget it
yeah we're talking about boolean
functions and then
this implication is just correct but for
non-boolean
for non-boolean there is uh there is a
star here
yeah right
uh
so and and as we said somehow
these two things are kind of orthogonal
to each other and
none of them is stronger than the other
so
none of these two implications are
correct
this as we said this is kind of tight
for
weighted majorities this is pretty bad
for weighted majorities if you check
this on majority
you will see that it misses again by
something like
root and instead of root n it will miss
out by a root n over login
so it's pretty bad but this is a sharp
for something called tribes
which roughly speaking is just
take your coordinates partition them
into
subsets of size roughly
log again each and then
inside each of these subsets you do a
an end between all of the things
and you do an or between the different
tribes
it's not very hard to check that this is
sharp and tribes is kind of like
you know it's an example where all the
influences are the same
and they are all of this order
login over and
good so we have this uh
thing and to complete the diagram
it's kind of natural to to ask you know
is there some inequality that we can
find
that implies both of these
and this is what uh asked
by the way i see there's there's quite a
lag between
uh my my voice
and the and the writing right
is it kind of okay because when i when i
look at the other screen i see that it's
really lagging
so if it's annoying let me know and
maybe we can try to
seems okay i think yeah okay
cool uh
okay so this is this is the question
that
that
you know this is a natural question that
telegram asked
and he even had a suggestion for
what this strengthening might be
okay so what he proposed is the
following inequality
the variance of f is hopefully bounded
by
this thing
but also hopefully we get to multiply by
the following thing
1 over log
of 1 over the sum
of the squares of the influences of f
with a square root
okay
so this this is what talagan suggested
it's clear that you know this
implication holds
and let me now also convince you
that this implication holds
as well
the other one so
so running in this inequality
the one over square root is not inside
the expectation right that's something
it's it's outside yeah yeah i mean it's
it's just a
constant this is this this thing doesn't
depend on x
right and and is it i mean
is there is there any intuition why the
lagrange suspected
this form of the inequality yeah yeah
okay i'll i'll okay so first let me show
you why this
actually implies yeah can i i mean
sure it's a general question i mean
maybe now we can comment on this later
so i mean if you replace boolean i mean
if you try to relax it to be in let's
say
almost bullion or being bounded or been
completely you know
mapping to r can you say at some points
what forms
stay true what stones are obviously
false i mean
uh
um maybe let me
try to discuss this in the end i mean
yeah there's there's several things i
can say
several other things i don't know but
uh but i think it's it's gonna be better
to try to discuss
because i mean we'll also see from the
proofs
where we actually extract you know use
the fact that it's put in
okay for example kkl
really needs the fact that all the
derivatives
can be either 0 1 or minus 1.
i mean if the function was very close to
1 or minus 1 on every point so it
wouldn't be true
sure so so it really just uses the fact
that the derivatives are
either zero or something that's actually
significantly bounded away for
from zero this is this is basically what
you need okay so saying so if it's
approximately
boolean it's still okay yes
for example i'm not sure because you can
have two values that are very close to
one
then their difference would be very
close to zero i mean yeah yeah as long
as
those differences have to be the same
order you know
that that contribute to the variance
sure
i mean if if you have you you could have
you know
minus one and then one and one minus
epsilon
but you only have like this one point
where you have minus one
and the whole game is between one and
one minus epsilon and then
as of shai says you can't really gain
anything
it has to be the case that you know the
contribution
that like most oscillations happens
where
you know the differences are quite large
sure
um yeah so so this is i guess what i
have to say for now
um on on the other hand what's written
here
it's it's like much less crucial that
the function is boolean okay and
and for this inequality we'll we'll see
what happens
but but but maybe it's a good time to
comment
that this kind of inequality one of the
first applications
was to show something for
uh first passage percolation i'm not
going to define what it is but it's
it's basically you have a percolation
and you
and and it determines the length it's
like the length of the shortest path
and then this function is not boolean it
takes
integer values but the derivatives are
you know integer
you're muted i
okay um
good so actually
um okay let let me go back just a little
bit
so this implication is not
quite true it's only true
for functions such that the variance is
omega of one but
uh there's an actual strengthening of
this conjecture this is what we're gonna
prove
so maybe let me now write the what the
strength and engage
let's try it's it's almost the same as
what's written here
but what you actually get to have
is this there exists a function g
such that everything i wrote here
holds but you also
get to put this function
g inside the expectation here
and g of x
is always between 0 and 1
and the expectation of the square of
g is at most the variance of f
so i i i feel like i might i
i don't wanna confuse you too much
i will just need this
thing in order for this implication to
hold true
but you know you can just ignore the
function g
if you want okay
uh obviously this is yet another
strengthening
just because you know g is between zero
and one
so i only made you know this thing
smaller
and now let's see uh how
let's call this inequality star
and let's see how star
implies the kkl inequality
this it's pretty easy but at least it'll
it'll give you some
intuition on you know what this thing is
good for
maybe so here's how this implication
works
so the inequality basically says that
the variance of f maybe let me write
here
times log
1 over the sum of squares of influences
is at most the expectation
of g root
the sensitivity i just copied the
inequality
but now let's use kashish words
and cautious words tells us that this is
at most
the square root of the expectation of g
square
times the square root of the expectation
of the sensitivity
now the expectation of the sensitivity
is
just equal to the
total influence of f
on the other hand we have this
inequality
so this
is at most root variance f
times total influence
and now i can divide by this divide both
sides by
the square root of the variance of f
and what we're gonna
have is that the variance of
f
is at most the sensitivity
over log of 1
over
the sum of squares of influences
and well
the sum is obviously
uh smaller equal like i guess
i'm talking about the denominator so
maybe
let me just write it here
is definitely smaller or equal than the
max
influence times the total influence
which means that you know this is
smaller than the total
influence log and here i can write
1 over the total influence
times 1 over the max
influence
and this is almost kkl right if if
if we could erase
this thing
sorry if we could erase not including
the log if we could erase just this
thing we would have kkl
exactly right
but the point is you know it's it's not
very hard to check that
if if if this is the dominant n
term right this this product becomes a
sum of logs
and if the first one is the dominant
term it basically means that the
influence of f is already very big
so kkl holds like trivially
so it's not hard to check that we can
actually
erase this thing okay so so
this is why this implies kkl okay and
and star is basically
so so this star here
is uh our first main theorem
and okay maybe let me let me say one
more thing
so uh just to give you uh
an intuition regarding the sum of
influences square
if you think about monotone functions
what what this is is just the
energy on the first level of
like the first level fourier energy
of the f
okay so
so basically what this inequality means
is
either there's
a considerable energy on the first level
which means that
f is very correlated with some linear
function
or if it's not which is equivalent
by a theorem of binaminikalayinchrom
to the fact that f is noise sensitive so
f is noise sensitive
if and only if this thing here
is little low of one in which case you
actually get a strengthening
of of the this
original inequality here
okay so so whenever f is noise sensitive
you get something which is strictly
better than what's written here
okay
um good and
before i continue i mean
let's continue and discuss one last
concentration inequality
again due to talaga but a different one
so this this one is the previous one was
telegram 94 and this one is
96 or something like that
and this is a strengthening of the kkl
inequality
so the kkl in quality told us again that
the variance of
f is at most and
let me write it a little bit differently
so the total influence
is the sum of influences
and here in the denominator we had log
of 1 over the max influence
and what are gone proved is that we can
actually
remove this max
right so this is a very natural thing to
expect
basically what this inequality is
telling us
is that you know the influence is
not is really not the right quantity
to measure the effective variance
in a certain direction when the function
is boolean the effective variance
is is really this thing like
those are the things that add up to the
entire variants and if you look at the
tribe's
function then you know this inequality
is sharp
i mean i i guess what i'm trying to say
is that
you know the the contribution of a
single coordinate
to the overall variance of the function
is this quantity here
written inside the sum
and
[Music]
there was a question
floating around of
trying to characterize so we know this
is sharp for tribes
but we'd like to characterize give some
characterization
of what does a function look like
when this inequality is sharp for which
what can i say
about functions such that this
inequality is sharp or
sharp up to a constant four and
our second theorem basically says that
if this inequality is sharp then you
have a lot
of vertex boundary so for this let me
just define
that
the vertex boundary of f is just
all the set of x
such that the gradient of
f at x is non-zero
and our theorem is
uh the following so if
i let's this
give this right hand side a name let's
call this
t of f and let's
uh define our
talaga of f
to be the ratio between the variance of
f and t of f
and you know the telegram inequality
just tells us that
this is at most one or at most some
constant i think you can actually take
one here
it doesn't matter so much and
the theorem says that
maybe let me write it here so the actual
theorem says
that if you take the variance of f
and multiply it by
this quantity over log
1 over
our tale of f so
this is clearly at most one just because
of
this inequality but what we show
is that this is also lower bounded by
the measure
of the vertex boundary of f
so one one consequence is that
you know if this thing is
actually one or omega of one
not much smaller then the vertex
boundary is of the same
order as that of the variance which
basically means that you know
most points so if
so you know the variance is kind of like
the expectation
here they're also the same order because
it's a boolean function
so it means that most points
where f is one or a proportion of points
where f is one are also
inside the vertex boundary and
a corollary of this
is uh
again a stabil
some kind of stability uh rebound
for the so-called isoparametric
inequality
so just to quickly remind you the
isoparametric inequality
says that the variance of f is at most
something like this this is a sharp
inequality it's
2 times
sorry let me just let me write it like
this
the total influence of f is at least 2
times the variance of f times
log
one over the variance of f
this is log base two this thing is sharp
for uh sub cubes
and
this is the isoparametric inequality the
corollary says
that if
i is
sharp up to a constant
if a function f almost saturates this
inequality
then in this
following weak sense it's it has it's
close to a sub-cube
in the sense that the measure
of the
inner inner vertex boundary this is a
bit stronger than the
vertex boundary of f
is at least some constant times the
measure
of the set where f is equal to one
so as a sub cube has all the points
inside the vertex boundary
if you almost saturate the isoparametric
inequality that
you have a proportion of the points
inside the vertex boundary
okay does it make sense
good so um
[Music]
those are the uh
theorems that we have
and in the time i have left i want to
talk to you a little bit about the
approach yeah
what is the definition of this uh
derivative plus ah
this is okay so uh
this this derivative was just vertex
boundary
and by derivative plus what i mean
is the inner vertex boundary so
these are the sets where f is equal to
one
and also they're in the vertex boundary
which is kind of much stronger it's it's
a stronger statement
because if you take a very small
sub cube say then
you have a lot more points in the vertex
boundary than
in the inner vertex boundary
right if it's co-dimension k then you
have a ratio of
k between the two so this is just i mean
the
the point that the fact that we can
take this plus here basically means that
we we get something that is sharp up to
a constant
um okay
so let's uh
start with some constructions towards
the approach
let just to to just a few general words
so maybe if i go back to this
diagram
uh i'm looking at the screen and it
seems like there is a lot of lag
okay so the poincare
quality here on top
has a very simple proof used in fourier
this inequality its first proof
due to telecom was uh some kind of
induction of
on coordinates whereas this inequality
the kkl inequality as well as the second
inequality by talaga
they're they're the main
component somehow in those proofs is
the hypercontractive inequality
our approach somehow completely
bypasses hyper contractivity
and just to give
a teaser for what's going on
is hyper contractivity basically
tells you like that the philosophy is
start
from the original function
apply some noise to it apply the heat
operator
and then you get some function which is
much much smaller
smoother and the hyper contractive
inequality tells you
how much smoother it is and the fact
that it's smooth lets you do
several things to it
we we kind of instead of hit equation
take a dual approach so heat equation
can
always be coupled with some diffusion
process
the heat equation you know in rn is the
expectation of the function on
some brownian motion started from a
point
and you know we can instead of applying
heat equation we can apply some
diffusion process
but in our proof it's really the
diffusion
process that we use is really analogous
to the reverse here equation
in the sense that if heat equation takes
a function
starts noising it and eventually reaches
something completely flat
which is the constant function in our
setting in in our approach we kind of
start with a function where you have no
information at all we start from a
constant thing
and we kind of go backwards in time
rather than
forwarding time eventually
ending up at the original function where
the
whole analysis is
is is looking at derivatives not as
things become more and more smooth but
as we have more and more information
about the function
so the this was very very general and i
know
it sounds very vague but i think
uh but but just keep it in mind
as as we go through the proof
okay okay so we
need
two uh general ingredients
for proofs the first one is
one that i guess you're all familiar
with
and this is the multi-linear
or the harmonic
extension
of a function
from the discrete cube
to its convexal
the continuous hypercube
so what is this so given a function
defined on the discrete hypercube
i guess everybody here
knows that it can be uniquely written as
the sum
over subsets
of coordinates of some coefficients
depending on those subsets
times the characters
which are just the product of
coordinates
in these subsets
okay so uh okay i wanted to move this
but it doesn't work
and f
hat which is often called the fourier
transform of f
is it exists and it's
also unique
okay so this is a
fact just follows from the earth
orthonormality of these characters
and this
expression basically automatically
induces
an extension of f into
the continuous hypercube right just by
we can we
this thing makes sense as a function
where those x i's are continuous
right so this
uh and by abuse of notation from now on
when we write f will
you know f can refer to both the
function
defined here or here
they coincide on the discrete hypercube
so it doesn't matter so much
and one thing to note is that this
expression is multilinear which means
that this function is harmonic and not
only it's harmonic
it's also harmonic in the relative
interior
of every one of the k facets
of the continuous cube so another way to
think about
this uh definition
which might make more sense for what
we're doing here
is to start from a function defined
here on the corners
and then we can harmonically uniquely
harmonically extend it
into the one facets of the hypercube
once we did that we can extend it inside
interpolate inside the two facets
harmonically
and so on until we get to interpolate
everything into the continuous cube
this would give the same result as you
know what this expression is
okay
so this is the harmonic extension
and the second ingredient is going to be
some kind of random walk i know i'm
basically
running out of time for the first hour
right so let me
just write uh a few more lines and then
you can
yeah sure uh
so our second ingredient is going to be
a process
bt
so a stochastic process t is going to be
between 0
and 1 and bt is going to
live inside
the continuous cube
and this process will be characterized
so i'm not going to give you the
explicit construction now
so this i will do after the break i'll
just
tell you there is a unique process which
is characterized by the following
properties
it's a pretty simple process
so the first property
is that well the process is essentially
one dimensional
in the sense that all coordinates are
iid
so i just need to tell you how one word
and it didn't
behave the second property
is that for all i
and all t
b t the i coordinate of
b of t is
in absolute value almost surely equal to
t
meaning that bt i is either
plus t or minus t
and the third property which is going to
be enough to give us a unique
characterization of what this is is that
bi of t is a martingale
okay so i guess this is a good time for
a break
because now in the break you can try to
think how to construct the process that
satisfies you know both two and
three
so these properties uniquely define the
process
or almost i mean
i'm cheating a tiny tiny bit by saying
uh the the those the
the time is continuous so the
martingales can be
either left or right semicontini
up to this tiny point
it's unique
okay sounds great so let's take a 10
minute break
when we come back if you have questions
it would be a good time to ask them
and see you after break